THOR MITCHELL: So thank you
everybody for joining us.
This is the Maps API
Fireside Chat.
We have a bunch of people up
here on the stage and a bunch
more people down at the
front here, all from
the maps API team.
So between us, hopefully
we can do our best
to answer your questions.
I will let everybody introduce
themselves,
starting with Sean.
SEAN ASKAY: All right, my
name is Sean Askay.
I'm a developer advocate on
the Google Earth Outreach
team, and I'm also the
tech lead for KML.
PETER BIRCH: I'm Peter Birch,
the product manager for Google
Earth product family, including
desktop and mobile
and also API.
And I've also been involved in
some of the Earth Engine work.
So if people have some questions
about that, I might
be able to answer some
of those as well.
SUSANNAH RAUB: Hello,
I'm Susannah Raub.
I am the tech lead for the
JavaScript Maps API.
THOR MITCHELL: My name's
Thor Mitchell.
I'm the product manager
for the Maps API
and the Places API.
JAMES MCGILL: My name
is James McGill.
I'm the tech lead for the Maps
Engine APIs and for KML on
Google Maps.
MANO MARKS: My name
is Mano Marks.
I'm the lead developer advocate
on the Google Maps
Developer Relations team.
I'm heading up our
outreach efforts.
THOR MITCHELL: OK, so we're
hoping you all came along
because you have plenty of
questions to ask, or this
could be a very short session.
MANO MARKS: By fireside chat,
we mean you chat us.
THOR MITCHELL: We have a mic at
the front and a mic and a
back there, and I
think we also--
do we have a roaming mic?
No, OK.
So anyone want to volunteer
to go first?
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Google Earth--
THOR MITCHELL: It's good--
you want to get it on
the video, too.
AUDIENCE: Hello?
There it is.
Google Earth API on mobile,
being able to integrate like
flyovers, things like that
in our own apps--
PETER BIRCH: I'm sorry,
I didn't--
AUDIENCE: Google Earth API,
like being able to do
flyovers, 3D stuff, so it's
not just like Street View
where it's just staggered
images, where it's more of a
smooth flow.
Google Earth has that on mobile,
but it's not an open
SDK or open API.
Is there any way that we can
access that in our own apps?
PETER BIRCH: Sure.
So there's a couple
ways right now.
So the question was about Google
Earth API on mobile and
what are some of the ways that
developers could take
advantage of this kind of full
immersive 3D, if I'm
paraphrasing that correctly.
AUDIENCE: Yep.
PETER BIRCH: So, first of all,
today there are some ways
developers can use that.
So one is through KML.
And if anyone also has more KML
questions, Sean is our KML
expert here.
We can talk more about
the nuances of it.
But it's a common markup
language, and that is
supported on mobile.
And that's supported actually
on Android and iOS.
And so if you do have KML, there
are some limitations.
But you'll be able to load that
onto the mobile device
and then view that content.
In addition, on Android we take
advantage of intents.
And so if you use the View
intent with a file type of KML
or KMZ, it will automatically
launch Earth.
And, for example, if it has
a tour in it, it will
automatically start
playing the tour.
So one really easy thing you
could do today is if you have
a flyover that you wanted as
part of your application, you
could basically just have a link
that would launch Earth
and then start playing
that flyover.
Now we often hear people saying,
hey, I want to be able
to do more than that.
I want to have a full SDK.
I want to be able to have full
programmability over that.
We don't have anything to
talk about right now,
unfortunately.
But it is something that we hear
more of, and we'd love to
hear more ideas and ways that
people might want to use
something like that.
AUDIENCE: So there's no way to
integrate that inside the app
instead of launching the
external Google Earth?
PETER BIRCH: Right.
So right now, there's no way of
integrating it within your
application.
AUDIENCE: OK, thank you.
AUDIENCE: I have a very cool app
that I have to deliver at
the end of July.
And I'm sort of wondering how
many of these APIs are
available for me to use today?
What are the chances I could
deliver that, number one, from
a technical point of view?
And then would there also be
the necessary documentation
and examples available to help
me use these new APIs?
MANO MARKS: Can you say
specifically which APIs you're
interested in?
AUDIENCE: Well, I have quite a
few point-in-polygon layers in
ArcView in Arc, And I want to
be able to upload those and
then combine those with some
other mapping data and ortho
photos and things like that.
MANO MARKS: So today, you can
upload all that to Maps
Engine, if you have a Maps
Engine account, and then serve
those out onto layers, onto a
Google Maps API application.
That's all available
right now.
AUDIENCE: Great.
And what about in terms of
examples and documentation?
MANO MARKS: We've got
fewer of those.
The Maps data layer is listed as
experimental because that's
our way of saying we're
testing this
particular piece out.
But you can ask questions
in our developer forums.
Specifically on Stack Overflow,
we're answering
questions there.
Just tag it as Maps API v3, and
then somebody will get to
answer your questions.
And also, I have a couple of
samples in my slide deck.
Which I did for Maps Engine, and
I'll publish that out to
Twitter tonight.
I guess.
And then there's also a code
lab tomorrow on Maps Engine
where you can take a lot
of that code with you.
AUDIENCE: So you would say the
odds are pretty good I should
be able to count on those
features and deliver?
MANO MARKS: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: First of all, thank
you for the transit API.
I have a project called Transit
& Trails, and we've
been waiting for that
for a long time.
It looks great.
I looked at the docs.
I was wondering about, is there
a way to get service
area boundaries for the agencies
that you do have in
the system and a way to get a
list programmatically of the
agencies that do provide
their data?
Because certain areas,
especially the Bay Area, has
lots of agencies and not
all of them are there.
So if we can provide a way to
our users to disable certain
features if they're looking in
an area that doesn't have
transit available, that
would be great.
Is there anything like that?
THOR MITCHELL: We did yesterday,
in conjunction with
the launch ad, update our FAQ,
and there is a link in there
that links to a list of all
the transit agencies, I
believe, that we include.
And we don't have coverage
polygons, I think is what
you're asking for.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
We're currently maintaining our
own polygons for service
area boundaries for the agencies
we know about.
But it'd be great if we could
get that programmatically for
all the other regions.
THOR MITCHELL: Yeah, I don't--
that's certainly not something
we currently provide.
I don't believe we expose that
on Maps either, so I'm not
sure that's something
we have in the
infrastructure at the moment.
There is a sort of manual
process you could go through.
We did introduce the
transit layer.
And if you were to take the
transit layer and take, for
example, our drawing tools, and
then refer to the list of
cities that we have, you could
actually just sketch out the
polygons yourself
fairly easily.
But it's a little bit
of a manual process.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, cool.
SUSANNAH RAUB: I'd also say,
file feature requests like
this, the team that maintains
all of this is not here.
And so we would need to
communicate back with Zurich
and find out what's even
possible on some of that.
AUDIENCE: Sure, absolutely.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: I was wondering if
there's any plans to support
Windows 7 multitouch in Earth
in either the thick or the
thin client?
PETER BIRCH: Yes, that's
something we definitely looked
at, and we just haven't
implemented it completely yet.
So you're talking about for a
touchpad, or are you talking
about for touchscreen?
AUDIENCE: For larger
touchscreens like perceptive
pixel devices, stuff
along that nature?
Basically, anything that runs
Windows 7 multitouch support.
PETER BIRCH: Yeah, I mean, it's
something that obviously
isn't there right now, but we
are definitely looking into
and would love to add.
AUDIENCE: Great.
PETER BIRCH: I mean, obviously,
from our mobile
devices, we've done a lot of
work already in terms of a
touch interface.
So we'd really like to bring
that to touchpads as well as
touchscreens on other
operating systems.
PETER BIRCH: All right, guys.
Don't be shy.
AUDIENCE: I've got lots
more questions.
So in talking with my Google
rep-- he's not a very
technical guy.
He always talks about, oh, you
know, Maps and Earth are kind
of merging together.
On the web, looking at it from
that perspective, what's the
roadmap for that?
And this is kind of a two-part
question, so
that's the first part.
I'll let you guys go.
PETER BIRCH: Excellent.
That's one of my favorite
questions.
So obviously--
MANO MARKS: Next question.
PETER BIRCH: --Maps
and Earth have a
lot of lineage together.
In fact, if you go back in
history and when Keyhole was
acquired, a lot of that
technology is what brought
satellite mode, for example,
to Google Maps.
And in 2008, I believe, we
launched Earth View in Google
Maps as well.
So we're always working and
trying to figure out how we
can bring these different
experiences to our users
wherever they are, right?
Now, there's going to be
technology limitations.
So, for example, in a browser,
there's certain things that
are easy to do and other things
that are hard to do.
And so, for example, when we
brought out the Earth API and
the plug-in, it's not because
we love plug-ins.
It's because that was the best
technical solution that we had
in order to bring that level
of rich, high-frame-rate
interactive graphics to
developers on the web.
Now, obviously as the web has
moved forward and there's a
lot of great new ideas and
technologies, we have WebGL.
Browsers such as Chrome have
gotten much faster.
And so we're obviously very
excited about some of the
possibilities there.
I think it's pretty fair
to say that we
are one family, right?
And we're trying to bring all
of our services to our
customers wherever they are.
And we're not done.
So we absolutely want to bring a
full immersive 3D experience
to every device you are and
be able to bring that
functionality across
with our products.
AUDIENCE: Very cool.
So is there like--
MANO MARKS: I have--
AUDIENCE: --an integration
point that's--
sorry, go ahead.
MANO MARKS: I was just going to
say, you can start to see
the beginnings of that with our
Maps GL experiment, how
we're doing some of the swooping
effects, and also the
way the Street View panoramas
work and a lot of other things
within that, and taking
advantage of WebGL.
I think it's a really--
I love it because I think it's
a really interesting problem.
Your next question is probably
going to be when.
I see that, yeah.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
MANO MARKS: And we're famous
for not giving an answer to
that question.
AUDIENCE: But there is a when?
MANO MARKS: We can't promise
any upcoming features.
But it's--
PETER BIRCH: Let me jump in.
We don't have anything to
announce at this time.
AUDIENCE: OK.
MANO MARKS: Yes.
Thank you, thank you.
I'm sorry, I forgot
my key phrase.
We don't have anything to
announce at this time.
But yeah, it's definitely
something we really find very
compelling and really
interesting.
And the host of new
technologies, particularly
vector rendering, what you're
seeing now on Android devices
in Maps, it brings out just
amazing possibilities.
And we're seeing both us and
people using our APIs leaping
forward with experiments on
these kind of technologies.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
The WebGL stuff is very,
very interesting.
And that leads into the second
part of the question is, kind
of through the grapevine, you
want to have web technologies,
mobile web stuff on mobile.
As far as bringing that onto
mobile using WebGL on Android,
the path forward on that.
PETER BIRCH: So I have some
thoughts on that.
I mean, obviously, mobile throws
an interesting twist in
everything, right?
Because you obviously want
something that's going to be
great performance,
and you want some
that's going to be portable.
And those things don't always
necessarily go together.
I think the best thing to say
is that we're very excited
about how to bring all
of this technology to
wherever users are.
And I think we will try to
figure out the best way to go
about doing that.
Today we provide a suite of
native APIs for Android with
our WebView APIs.
And you also have the option
of using the JavaScript v3
APIs, and we kind of have
that whole suite.
And so we're excited about
bringing all of this
to mobile as well.
Obviously, we announced
yesterday the new version of
Google Earth, and we actually
launched it on mobile first,
which is the first time
we've ever done that.
So, obviously, mobile is very
much on our minds, and we're
always looking at ways of how
we can bring that to our
developers as well.
AUDIENCE: Cool.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi, John Coryat
with USNaviguide.
I have a lot of v2 pages, like
50,000 of them, running
GAdsManager.
And I was wondering how does the
v3 ads performance compare
to v2 ads performance
in terms of revenue?
Is it equal?
Is it up, down, same ads?
Can you give me some perspective
on that?
THOR MITCHELL: Mike, would you
like to answer that question?
MIKE FERRO: Underlying, it
should be the similar
performance.
We're using the same--
oh, do you want me up?
Denied.
MANO MARKS: Mike was trying
to avoid this earlier.
MIKE FERRO: Hi there.
I guess I should introduce
myself.
My name is Mike Ferro.
I'm an engineering manager in
Sydney working on geo stuff.
GAdsManager, now the Ad Unit,
the Google Maps Ad Unit--
MANO MARKS: Sorry, go ahead.
MIKE FERRO: Thank you.
Oh, that's much better.
MANO MARKS: I was just getting
a gesture from him.
It
MIKE FERRO: Did you all
hear the intro?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
MIKE FERRO: Yeah, OK.
So short answer, you should
see similar performance.
We're using the same underlying
targeting
mechanisms, basically looking
at what users might be
interested in when looking
at this place.
For those of you that haven't
seen that, we use a form of
ads targeting that says using
historical data in aggregate,
what might users be interested
in when looking at Orlando?
It turns out they may be
interested in Disney World.
So we'll maybe show a Disney
World app, a little bias
towards that, certainly.
Similar underlying mechanism
for v2 and v3.
AUDIENCE: I have to say that
performance of the Map ads has
been just phenomenal.
The income from it is why
I'm here pretty much.
So I'm a little leery about
changing anything because it's
just so good, and it seems
to just ever increase.
So you think it's safe
for me to go into
the v3 water on that?
MIKE FERRO: So one of the hats
I wear, I look at ads for
Google Maps.
And in general, what we do on
Maps, like if there's a
revenue question, one of the
great things about ads in
general is that you get really
good data that you can track,
and that allows us to do
fine-grained experiments.
So rather than definitively
answering this for you,
because I can't really, what I
would suggest is try it out.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
MIKE FERRO: Run it on some
percentage of traffic, if you
have the capability, or try
it out for some days.
You'll very quickly
get the answer.
You can try it on some
of your sites.
I know you're running a
whole bunch of them.
You were actually a partner
for us fairly early on.
AUDIENCE: Right.
MIKE FERRO: Which is
really exciting.
The performance has varied
across various types of sites.
Try it out.
AUDIENCE: OK, I guess I will.
MIKE FERRO: And good luck.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Could you please tell us
anything about your road map
in adding special query
capabilities to the API, more
specifically making a special
query between own content and
Google Maps?
MANO MARKS: So are you talking
about in the JavaScript API,
or are you talking about
in Google Maps Engine?
AUDIENCE: Perhaps
with the engine.
I don't know.
We are making special analyses
using our own data.
We are using our GIS link
library and our GIS server,
making mashups.
Are you thinking on, our case
for example, any other
alternative in the future?
MANO MARKS: Right.
So in Google Maps Engine,
Dylan Lorimer announced
yesterday that by the end of
the year, we'll have basic
create, read, update, and
delete operations, which
should include queries.
We can't say when we'll have
specific features.
But obviously, spatial queries
make a huge amount of sense
for Maps Engine and would be a
pretty natural fit for that.
So yeah, I mean, again, I
can't commit to specific
features and when we get.
But by the end of the year, we
should have your basic query
and create, read, update,
delete operations.
JAMES MCGILL: So For those not
familiar with Maps Engine,
this is our enterprise
geospatial cloud product.
So the idea is we make it very
easy for you to take your data
that you have uploaded
into our cloud.
We perform processing
on that data.
And by the end of the year,
we're going to have APIs so
that you can get back that data,
run queries over it,
access subsets of it.
We've also got great integration
with the Maps API,
which is already launched.
So we can render that data
server side as tiled overlays,
which allows us to very
efficiently show very large
data sets on top of
the Maps API.
And then you can integrate
that with all the other
components of the
API, so Street
View, editable polygons.
So that allows you to build
really rich applications
without having to worry about
how you host that data and how
you make it globally available
and reliably available.
MANO MARKS: And we did a session
earlier in Google I/O,
which is recorded and should be
published as a video within
the next 24 hours, Enterprise
Geospatial in Google's Cloud.
It talks through it.
Sean Maday and I did it.
Sean did a demo of using Maps
Engine, and then I showed some
of the developer components that
exist today and talked a
little bit about the future.
JAMES MCGILL: And I believe
there's a code lab tomorrow--
MANO MARKS: Yes, that's right.
JAMES MCGILL: --as well, which
should go into some of those
processes as well.
So that may be worth
attending.
MANO MARKS: Sean Wohltman and
Mike Evanoff are running a
code lab tomorrow, where you get
hands-on access to what we
currently have available
in the API.
AUDIENCE: Sorry.
AUDIENCE: This is a question
about the offline mapping.
I know there was a big talk.
It was big feature.
I don't think it was
talked that much in
the past two days.
What is the best solution?
It would be the Google
Earth portable?
Or would it be the
Google Maps?
What's the best solution
for offline mapping?
No connectivity, no internet.
THOR MITCHELL: A crack team
of experts with us today.
DYLAN LORIMER: I asked him
to ask this question.
So my name is Dylan Lorimer.
I'm one of the product managers
with all these folks
on the Geo team.
And I'm specifically product
manager for the Google Earth
portable, which you mentioned.
So I think the question was,
what's the best solution for
offline use of Maps?
It really depends on
the situation.
I think you saw the announcement
two or three
weeks ago that we're enabling on
Google Maps for mobile the
ability to offline or cache
content for use in
disconnected environments like
when you go on holiday in
Europe, and you don't want
to incur roaming charges.
It's really targeted towards
the consumer use.
Do you want to describe
your use case a bit?
AUDIENCE: Well for us
it would be for
disaster response teams.
So we're kind of looking
at global,
like our entire country.
I was actually trying to
get it on my phone.
It limits the extent of your
actual offline capabilities on
my phone, so I can't actually
get a whole country.
DYLAN LORIMER: OK, so you
mentioned the Google Earth
portable, and that's actually
a solution that we launched
about a year and a half ago.
And it hasn't seen
a lot of fanfare.
But it's actually had quite a
lot of use for these types of
scenarios--
disaster response
and humanitarian
response types of events.
What it lets you do is, kind
of for your own data-- not
Google's content, but the
data that you provide--
you could basically create
those little caches.
And they're really only
restricted in overall storage
that you have.
So they're not really
little caches.
They can be quite
large, in fact.
And they can be deployed on
laptops or on mobile devices.
And they can launch, essentially
Google Earth or a
Google Maps-like front end.
And you can have a complete
mapping experience in the
field with no connectivity
required.
They also can broadcast.
So if you run this little
cache on your laptop, we
provide a server.
And you can actually share the
tile feed, essentially, for
other users on your network to
connect to from Google Earth
or web-based mapping interfaces
to consume the tiles.
AUDIENCE: What about
mobile, Dylan?
DYLAN LORIMER: Yeah, so the
portable solution runs on
laptops today.
We're very interested
in how we can do it
on mobile as well.
We don't have any big
announcements
around that right now.
But taking a step back for a
minute, we're really promoting
this idea of using Google's
cloud to upload your data and
to build maps with.
But we know that in many cases
you have to deploy those maps
out into the field for
those purposes.
So we're certainly interested
in how we can let you take
that content out of Google's
cloud and easily
cache it, so to speak.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
DYLAN LORIMER: Sure thing.
PETER BIRCH: If no one else asks
a question, we're going
to start singing.
AUDIENCE: I'm trying
to avoid coming up.
Sorry, I've got so
many questions.
MANO MARKS: You don't
me to start singing.
AUDIENCE: Imagery with
Street View.
Any way along a given route or
path to get all available
Street View images and points,
where all those are taken?
THOR MITCHELL: Not currently,
although it is a question that
comes up fairly regularly, so
it is something that we have
been known to discuss.
AUDIENCE: Great.
And the 45-degree cool 3D
building stuff, unfortunately,
I can't bring in Google Earth
into stuff we're using.
I'd love to.
Any chance of bringing
it into Maps?
PETER BIRCH: Fight over it.
We don't have anything to
announce at this time.
SEAN ASKAY: All right.
Next.
PETER BIRCH: But it sounds
like a really cool idea.
AUDIENCE: I like that.
PETER BIRCH: We'll take it
under consideration.
AUDIENCE: Hi, Randy First
from Logitech.
I'm looking at it from an
enterprise perspective.
We'd like to have indoor maps
that are private to our
company, not shared outside.
And also the feature that was
shown yesterday in the keynote
of the Street View indoors
seems really interesting.
Any idea of how we would get
something like that for our
internal use?
JAMES MCGILL: So Maps Engine
for the indoor maps is
probably a good fit.
So Maps Engine allows you to ACL
your data so you can keep
it private just within
your organization.
You can share it with other
people in your org so that you
can collaborate.
And then you've got fine-grained
ACL on how that
data is distributed outside
your organization.
You could push some of it
publicly if you wanted to
build a floor plan that
everybody had access to, or
you can keep it locked down.
And for example, if you use
map dot [INAUDIBLE]
in the Maps API today, you
have the option of having
users authenticate via OAuth 2.0
in order to view that map.
And then that guarantees that
only the people you want to
see it will be able to see it.
So using that, plus the ability
to store vector data
and render those vectors on top
of Google's existing base
map, you should be able to build
compelling floor plans,
which you're able
to lock down.
MANO MARKS: You have to do a
little bit of playing around
for floors.
Actually, if you take a look at
the Google I/O app on your
Android device if you've got
that, we did something
similar, although not using Maps
Engine, but just using
different floor plans and just
having a little control that
adds on the floors.
So you press 2 to get to
the second floor, 3 for
the third, et cetera.
So that's all doable with
the JavaScript API Maps
Engine right now.
One thing we don't have, and I
just mention this because it
came up in the last session,
is we don't have routing
within Maps Engine.
So we don't have a way to allow
you to do routing over
your own data, which would
be a nice feature.
AUDIENCE: And then
the second part--
MANO MARKS: James can build
that tomorrow, I'm sure.
AUDIENCE: The second part was
the Street View indoor views
of the office layout itself.
THOR MITCHELL: The Maps API does
allow you to build street
view panoramas based on
your own imagery.
You do have to stitch that
panorama together yourself and
tile it and host those tiles.
But it provides the methods
you need to define the
orientation of the panorama, the
links between panoramas,
and then put that into the
familiar Street View interface.
So we don't currently have a
purpose-built hosting solution
for that, although obviously you
could host that imagery on
App Engine or such like.
But the capability is there in
the Maps API to offer custom
Street View panoramas.
On And we have seen a number of
organizations use that to
provide indoor imagery.
You can even connect--
I realize you may not want to do
this in an ACL environment.
But on public sites, within the
Maps API, you can connect
that into the existing
Street View graphs.
You can move seamlessly
from Google imagery
into your own imagery.
AUDIENCE: So I actually
wanted to ask
about that same question.
How do I get my business
on the indoor--
not indoor mapping, but the
indoor visualization that they
showed in the I/O at
the first keynote?
THOR MITCHELL: The Street
View imagery?
AUDIENCE: Not the Street View
imagery, the indoor imagery.
THOR MITCHELL: Right.
But sorry, the indoor
photos or actually
the floor plan maps.
AUDIENCE: Indoor photos.
You may not be the team
for that or--
THOR MITCHELL: Yeah, I don't
know off the top of my head,
but I can find out.
So if you grab me later--
MANO MARKS: I'm sorry, is the
question how do you get your
business into there?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
MANO MARKS: Yeah, currently,
as far as I know, it's a
US-only program.
No?
OK, he just expanded that.
Nabil will probably answer
this question.
PETER BIRCH: You should get a
prize if you bring another
Googler up on stage, I think.
MANO MARKS: Hey, Dylan
got off the stage.
MALE SPEAKER: I'm not actually
part of the team, but there's
a website you can go to where
you request for a photographer
to come to your business.
They'll take photos inside, and
then they'll put it in.
So it's a program that we
run globally right now.
MANO MARKS: It's called Business
Photos, I think is
the public name.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah, I think if
you just search for like
Google Maps indoor business
photos or something like that,
there'll be a link.
And then you can just say
send a photographer
to my place of business.
AUDIENCE: OK, and
to be clear--
MANO MARKS: And you end
up having to pay the
photographer.
I mean, It's not
a free service.
AUDIENCE: I see.
So it's not--
a few weeks ago--
MALE SPEAKER: Are you sure?
MANO MARKS: I thought I was--
MALE SPEAKER: I don't.
MANO MARKS: I thought
that was true.
AUDIENCE: So a few
weeks ago, Google
brought out the backpack.
It was at a mapping event.
They brought out the backpack
where somebody gets to walk
through a building and
take full panoramas.
I want that guy to come to my
office and take pictures so I
can get it out on
the internet.
PETER BIRCH: Yeah, so what we
announced a couple of weeks
ago is something called Trekker,
and that's really a
continuation of the
Street View.
So basically we started with
streets, and we can drive
around, and we can take a lot
of different imagery and
provide the great Street
View experience we had.
But there are some places
we couldn't drive.
And so we created the trike.
And that allowed us to go and
gather that same imagery in
places that were too narrow
or pedestrian walkways.
And then there were ski slopes,
and so we have a
snowmobile.
And we were able to get some
great imagery, including, for
example, the Vancouver Winter
Olympics and things like that.
It turns out there's still some
other places that none of
those vehicles will actually
get us to.
But we managed to actually strap
the trike onto a boat to
get the Amazon.
So we were able to kind of
purpose that, including, I
think, on a rail car
on the Swiss Alps.
So we have some great
imagery there.
The Trekker is our latest foray
into how can we bring
beautiful views of places to our
users in places where all
you can do is hike or
cross country ski
or some other things.
So that will be something where
you'll start to see
imagery showing up of, for
example, Grand Canyon or other
national parks and
other places.
But that's not something that
is currently available for
businesses or third parties.
AUDIENCE: OK, so there's no
real way for me to either
submit those panoramas myself
to appear as part of Google?
I realize I think you addressed
this gentleman's
question before as how I could
add those images for my own
use as a layer on top of
the existing maps.
I think you understand
my question.
THOR MITCHELL: Certainly, the
indoor photos program,
business photos program, the
photographers that go out have
been trained to capture the
imagery in a specific way we
need with particular
equipment.
Extending that to be arbitrary
user-supplied
content would be--
it would have a lot
of overhead.
We'd have to do a lot
of review and--
it could become quite
frustrating if what you've
done doesn't quite match our
requirements but it looks good
enough for you.
So right now, we only send out
trained photographers.
PETER BIRCH: Just one
last thing on that.
MANO MARKS: What I was going
to say is there's nothing
stopping you from creating your
own Maps API application,
putting it on your website,
and using your own imagery
within a Street View
panorama there
that's hosted for yourself.
PETER BIRCH: Yeah, and there
are also some user photo
communities, including
Panoramio, which is a Google
service, and ones like
360Cities, which have a
fantastic collection
of photos.
And in fact, in Google Earth,
I believe in Google Maps as
well, we have a layer of
360Cities panoramas.
So there are communities out
there where you can actually,
if you have high-quality
photos, upload.
Those can be seen by a large
number of users.
THOR MITCHELL: And also, it's
a lesser-known fact that the
Panoramio layer in the v3 Maps
API allows you to actually
specify a specific user,
a Panoramio user
whose photos to show.
So you can actually display a
layer of photos on your map
which you can click on and it
will open up and give you
larger versions and then
restrict that to only photos
that you've taken.
MANO MARKS: Although Panoramio,
to be fair, is not
for indoor photography
primarily.
It's for panoramic landscape
photography.
AUDIENCE: With the trike,
do you have a program to
collaborate with the rail
trail organizations?
MANO MARKS: Sorry, could
you repeat that?
AUDIENCE: The trike.
Do you have a program to
collaborate with rail trail
organizations, bike trail?
PETER BIRCH: Yeah, I think--
so is the question about
Rails-to-Trails--
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PETER BIRCH: --and whether we're
collaborating with them?
We actually did collaborate with
them in terms of getting
that information into our biking
directions, just as I
know one partnership.
I do not know if we are having
any partnership in terms of
getting imagery of
those trails.
So I imagine that's the type of
thing that would be great
for our users, but I don't know
if we have any specific
arrangement with them.
AUDIENCE: You can't announce
a date then.
MANO MARKS: And by the way, I
don't know how to get you to
be a Street View driver.
That's another question that
comes up very often.
I can't comment on that.
AUDIENCE: OK, we're working
with a couple of customers
into police and intelligence
services, and internet is not
an option for them.
They can, of course, use Google
Earth Enterprise, but
they would love to get
it with your data.
Is that a possibility?
Not now, I know, but
in the future?
PETER BIRCH: I didn't actually
hear the whole question.
Did you get that, Dylan?
DYLAN LORIMER: Yeah.
PETER BIRCH: We should hand out
Map stickers every time--
DYLAN LORIMER: Hey there.
My name is Dylan Lorimer.
And In addition to the portable,
I also product
manage Google Earth
Enterprise.
So I think the question was
is there a way to provide
Google's content for use with
Google Earth Enterprise?
For the benefit of everyone,
Google Earth Enterprise is an
on-premise solution that Google
provides that lets
organizations build their own
maps and their own Google
Earths using the same technology
that we use at
Google in our cloud but provided
for on-premise use.
And we don't provide content.
We basically give you tools
for you to use your own
content to build your
own globes and maps.
And it's amazing to see
organizations that are
actually building really
purposeful--
maps specific to their
use cases.
To answer your question, no,
we don't provide Google's
content today.
It's come up quite a lot.
A lot of organizations are
interested in that, of course.
I think it's something we'd
like to consider.
And with the announcement a few
weeks ago of being able to
provide some of Google's content
cached in mobile
devices, that could open
some opportunities.
But we don't have anything to
announce today, to use the
term I just heard from you.
Which organization
are you from?
AUDIENCE: Private one.
DYLAN LORIMER: Oh,
OK, private one.
PETER BIRCH: More questions?
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I think I may have asked
somebody about this at one of
the talks earlier.
But we had some developers
recently that on their own
time they were developing some
pretty cool applications with
Maps and Fusion Tables.
And we liked it so when we went
to commercialize it, we
kind of ran into a brick wall
because we can't use Google
apps for domains and put
Fusion Tables in there.
So I'm wondering is that
something that might be
changed in the future?
Or do we need to look at Maps
Engine for the way to
commercialize that?
THOR MITCHELL: So the question
is about Maps Engine
integration with Apps
for your domain.
PETER BIRCH: Well, it's slightly
different than that.
I think there's a separate
question about Fusion Tables.
And I think that Fusion Tables
is a great technology, and I
think its application for
mapping has got a lot of
people excited.
And I think what we're really
trying to do is take a lot of
that technology through Maps
Engine to be able to bring
that to our geo developers.
And so as we bring in new
capabilities and new features,
Maps Engine is really the
platform we're looking to
bring that.
Now specifically in terms of
Maps Engine Google and Google
Apps for domain, that's
a Dylan question.
DYLAN LORIMER: So the question
is around Maps Engine running
on corporate domains
at Google, right?
So all of our products at Google
when we're building
them for the enterprise, they
should just work on corporate
domains, essentially.
And Map Engine's no exception.
It's not included in
the default Google
Apps product suites.
You don't pay $50 and get Maps
Engine enabled on your domain.
We have a different
pricing model.
But we integrate very
well with it.
So all the administrative
tools just work.
All the users in your domain,
you can provision to have
access to Maps Engine.
When you share and publish maps,
those same users can get
access to them.
So it fits really well into
the Apps ecosystem.
AUDIENCE: A few weeks ago, I
read something like Google
Places will be subsumed
in Google+, yes?
For example, what I understood
is that in Google Places, a
page of the owner would
be a Google+ profile,
something like that.
Is that it?
Or nothing to do?
THOR MITCHELL: So yes, a
couple of weeks ago, we
launched Google+ Local, which
essentially is a new
destination for the information
we collect and
offer around businesses
and reviews, scores.
It's a much more social
experience.
It's integrated with Google+.
You can contribute
your own reviews.
You can see reviews that
people in your
circles have submitted.
And as part of that, we are
migrating from the old Google
Place pages to have Google+
Local pages instead.
So as a result, yes, we
will be migrating
the existing place--
I don't know actually whether
it's the account as much, as
just the public-facing Place
pages into Google+.
AUDIENCE: For example, if we are
saying Google Places API,
it will be different now?
MANO MARKS: No.
THOR MITCHELL: No, this is
actually a point of confusion
which we should have
seen coming.
There was some concern
that when--
there were a lot of articles
that said Google Places is
being replaced with Google+
Local, that there was an
assumption that the Google
Places API would follow suit.
And that's not the
case at all.
In fact, the Places API is
something that we launched at
I/O last year, if you are
not familiar with it.
And then we continue to develop
at a pace, and we
launched a whole wealth of new
features just in the last
couple of days, including access
to reviews, the same
reviews you see on Google+
Local, access to paging so you
can get more results
than you used to
previously be able to get.
Also, more advanced text search
features, better for
desktop and speech-based apps.
And also we're adding opening
hours information to the
Places API as well.
So the Places API is healthfully
expanding its
capabilities.
And obviously, with
the move into--
the move of Google Places into
Google+ Local, that does raise
some interesting possibilities
for directions we can take the
Places API in the future to
also to be more social.
And that's something that
we're looking into.
AUDIENCE: Where do you
get your street map
and cadastral data?
Do you get that from local
agencies, or do you develop
that yourself?
PETER BIRCH: I'm sorry,
street map?
AUDIENCE: Street map and
cadastral data, property
information?
THOR MITCHELL: We source
them from a
wide variety of sources.
And actually, several of our
sources have asked not to be
identified so they don't get
inundated with lots of
information.
But we have then moved and
shifted to our Ground Truth
project, which Brian McClendon
mentioned, which we are then
continually propagating
our own data.
So a lot of it is looking at
satellite imagery and finding
street maps from there.
And plus, we add in additional
edits from Map Maker.
Now, there are some countries
where we haven't launched Map
Maker or the Ground
Truth project yet.
And so we're still sourcing
from a variety of licensed
data from other sources.
But we just this month announced
10 new countries
that we moved to Map Maker.
So we are very interested in
getting data from the user
community, who is most
interested in making sure that
the maps are up to date.
AUDIENCE: The reason I asked had
to do with how up to date
the maps were.
Because if the cities or
counties and things like that
are providing the data to
you, then I guess they--
MANO MARKS: Yeah, I mean, it's
basically a very large
operation to constantly be
sourcing new data and also to
be constantly looking at
satellite imagery and making
sure it's up to date and
incorporating user edits.
PETER BIRCH: And just to add to
that, if you look at Google
Maps 2005, we were very
dependent on licensed data.
And that created a lot of
limitations for us in terms of
quality, in terms of the ability
to update it quickly,
in terms of getting coverage
in other countries.
And so both the Map Maker
project that we've talked
about as well as this Ground
Truth, or GT, project that
Brian mentioned are hugely
ambitious efforts that we've
launched to really just up the
quality of our maps and the
coverage of our maps by taking
it on ourselves.
It's something that has been
a major focus of our teams.
And I don't know if you actually
got a chance to see
his talk at all, and he talked a
little bit about the process
by which we go through and
actually get the data.
We're combining it with publicly
available sources,
including using our own Street
View data where we can
actually go in and look at
the streets and use image
recognition to look at street
signs and all these things.
There's a lot of science and
engineering in there to be
able to create the
coverage and the
quality of that map data.
MANO MARKS: And I'm particularly
proud of the Map
Maker project because there was
a huge percentage of the
population--
I think it was actually over
half the population of the
Earth lived in places where
there wasn't decent digital
coverage at all.
I mean, you could actually go
to some countries and see a
few major roads in like
Hyderabad in 2008 and that
would be it.
And we've now richly mapped
areas that had never really
had that level of mapping,
at least in a
digital form before.
So I'm really proud of that
particular piece of it.
AUDIENCE: It's an absolutely
astounding project.
I can't believe you guys
are doing this.
The second question that I had
had to do with metadata
associated with the shapefiles
and things like that.
I noticed that there were
keywords that you could
associate with it.
But we have a great deal more
metadata that are associated
with each of the sets of data
having to do with who
collected it, under what
standards it was collected,
and things like that.
Is there the opportunity
to upload that
information as well?
MANO MARKS: Are you talking
about in Maps Engine?
PETER BIRCH: We're going to
bring Dylan up to talk about
metadata for shapefiles,
I believe.
DYLAN LORIMER: Yeah.
Are you talking about in
Google Maps Engine?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
DYLAN LORIMER: Hey, my name is
Dylan Lorimer, and I'm also
the product manager for
Maps Engine, so
this is a great question.
So the question's on metadata.
And this is actually a really
interesting topic, and I'm
actually interested in
your feedback here.
So today when you upload
shapefiles or CSVs or KMLs, we
do our best to preserve
the metadata.
We let you also apply your own
so you can tag the data with
arbitrary keywords.
And we have some customers that
use that mechanism to
define their own kind
of taxonomy,
essentially, for the data.
What we don't do a great job
of, though, is taking your
metadata and kind of
trying to map it to
well-known specs or standards.
I know there are
some out there.
The FGDC and INSPIRE in Europe
have put a lot of
thought into this.
We're really keen to figure out
what the right story is
there, and we really
want your feedback.
So my point is that we
preserve your data.
We let you apply your own tags,
and we index that and
make it searchable.
We don't yet have a great story
on schema mapping and
how to expose that in
more useful ways.
AUDIENCE: So we would put our
metadata in there as sort of
keyword phrases that we
ourselves would understand
what the meaning were
as opposed to
some sort of standard?
DYLAN LORIMER: Today.
That's how you do it today,
but we do preserve it.
If you were to upload sidecar
files or associated files that
have an FGDC-style schema, we'll
preserve that today.
We just don't yet parse it and
make use of it in a good way.
We're really keen to do so.
It's come up with numerous of
our government customers
specifically, who want to be--
to leverage standards and have
better interoperability, so
we're keen to help
you out there.
AUDIENCE: The government of
British Columbia is working on
a project to try to create a
single database for all of the
mapping data that's collected.
And all of this mapping data is
so fragmented, it's what I
call weak data.
And once it's brought
together, it
will be very powerful.
However, one of the concerns
that people have is the
quality of the data.
And it's not like there's good
quality or bad quality.
There are varying levels of
veracity that you assign to
any given data set.
And so having standards to
understand it and another
metadata would be really
important to
make this data powerful.
DYLAN LORIMER: How would you
want to expose that through
APIs as well?
I'm curious if there's a way you
want to expose attributes
for third parties or developers
to query.
AUDIENCE: Well, the biggest
problem is what you mentioned
before, which is having a
standard set of keywords that
define specifically what
the attributes mean.
So adopting a standard, which
if they are out there, would
be the most important.
And then in terms of the API,
just something like a keyword
value pair would probably be--
or XML would probably be a
good way to structure it.
But it's the standards
that are, I
think, really important.
DYLAN LORIMER: And then when you
query the metadata, do you
want to be able to do like
inequalities on it or just
keyword lookup?
Like do you want to say like
greater than, less than type
of operations?
AUDIENCE: Oh, yes.
Oh, yeah, we'd need a full
query capability.
DYLAN LORIMER: OK, thanks.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
PETER BIRCH: All right,
who's next?
AUDIENCE: Last question,
I think.
Static maps.
When a static map is delivered,
you get a drawn
route on it.
It's really frustrating to try
to find that map, that point.
We've had to do some kind of
hairy math, which you are much
better at doing than us.
It would be really cool to
encode that route data on the
PNG or something similar to that
so that the route on the
static map is delivered back.
Any thoughts on that?
THOR MITCHELL: So you're saying
how do you get the
textual instructions that
go with an image?
AUDIENCE: So we get an image
that's a static map with a
route on it.
Knowing where that route is on
the image in a per-pixel, like
where is the red line type of
thing, it doesn't come back
with the data.
So we need to calculate that and
it's somewhat inaccurate
on our side.
THOR MITCHELL: So there's two
parts of this, actually.
One is the service that provides
the polylines that
are drawn on a static map is the
same service that drives
the directions API, and the
directions API does return a
polyline as a vector for you.
I realize that, however, if
you're looking to pick out the
individual pixels, that might
not be what you need.
But it does give you
the sequence of
vertices on that polyline.
What I have seen someone do,
which I thought was pretty
creative, was request
two static maps.
One is a normal static map which
has the map on and has
the polyline on.
The other is a static map where
they've used star maps
to turn the entire map white
and then specify that the
polyline be rendered in black.
So what you end up with is a
bitmap that tells you where
the polyline is on
the static map.
AUDIENCE: Very cool, but if
it's a very intricate map,
it's hard to get turns
and distances.
THOR MITCHELL: Right.
In which case, you need the
directions web service because
the directions web service will
give you the polyline,
but it will also give you the
time and distance along each
step and textual directions.
And obviously, you can take that
polyline, and you can use
the geometry library that we
have to calculate other things
about that that you might
need as well.
AUDIENCE: But the static image
that comes back, the bounding
of it is different.
And so knowing where 0, 0 is
and where the line starts--
SUSANNAH RAUB: It sounds to me
like you're going to need to
use a combination of tools for
what you're trying to do.
And without knowing exactly the
problem that you're trying--
what your actual goal is, it's
hard for us to necessarily
engineer that solution here.
AUDIENCE: Is there a way
that it can code
that data in the PNG?
MANO MARKS: It seems like this
might be a good question on
Stack Overflow, and then we
can sort of dive into it a
little bit more deeply.
Or one of us in the Sandbox
could talk to you about it
more deeply offline.
AUDIENCE: OK.
All right, thank you.
AUDIENCE: So some of the new
stylistic tools that you
introduced in the Maps API, like
the dashed polylines and
the symbols and some of that,
is there any plans to port
that to the Earth API and
then furthermore into
the KML spec itself?
You haven't had a
question yet.
SEAN ASKAY: I'm so sorry,
could you repeat that?
I'm not sure if I quite caught
the first half of it.
AUDIENCE: So some of the new
stuff that you introduced in
the Maps API, like
stylistically, like the dashed
polylines and the symbols and
arrowheads, is there any plans
on introducing that into KML and
also into the Earth API?
SEAN ASKAY: Yeah, so we're
definitely interested in
adding richer styling
features to KML.
We're currently working with the
Open Geospatial Consortium
to revision KML.
And there have been a lot of
proposals from other groups to
the standard to do just that, to
add dotted lines, different
types of highlighting
and stuff.
We don't have anything
to announce yet.
AUDIENCE: Of course.
SEAN ASKAY: But it's definitely
something that both
Google and people outside of
Google interested in the KML
standard are very keen on
working on, and it's a
personal interest of mine.
So nothing right now, but
we're thinking about it.
AUDIENCE: OK, second question.
A lot of our end users complain
specifically in Earth
about the way disambiguation is
handled, like i.e. you have
10 ships in a port, and it's
very hard to see stacked up
what's actually there.
I was wondering if that's
something that's been
commented on.
Any plans to address
it, et cetera?
PETER BIRCH: So are you thinking
about the desktop
client or the API?
AUDIENCE: Desktop client more
specifically, but if it was
something that was going to
be improved in the API.
PETER BIRCH: Yeah, I
mean, so this is a
hard problem to solve.
AUDIENCE: Agreed.
PETER BIRCH: And I think there's
more flexibility in
the API in terms of returning
a list that might--
if you have a hit,
and you could get
back a list of objects.
In the desktop client, one of
the challenges we have is that
the user is the one driving
the experience.
And they could have any number
of different layers on that
could have no correlation
with each other, right?
So you might have the
photo later on.
You might have a couple of other
layers from the gallery,
and then you might have
your own content.
And if you click on a point, we
need to let the user-- we
need the user to give us more
information about which one
they're looking at.
We have the-- we call it the
turkey tail disambiguation
right now, which is not--
MANO MARKS: I call
it the star.
PETER BIRCH: The star, sorry.
AUDIENCE: Starfish is
what we call it.
PETER BIRCH: Which has
some challenges.
And I think we'd love to hear
some more ideas about what
would work better for you in
terms of ways to make it
easier for users to kind of--
because we still do need the
information from the user,
which is which of the various
things that you've just
intersected with is the
one that you're
most interested in.
And we don't want to get in the
mode where we just show
the top one because that is
going to hide some data.
AUDIENCE: Right.
Maybe--
MANO MARKS: I think there's
a lot that you
can do server side.
You could do originated KML
network link hierarchy that
would, at a higher level
aggregate into a single
placemark with a list within the
description balloon of all
those ships in port
or whatever.
And as you get in closer,
it spreads it out.
Something along the similar
lines but for the Maps API is
our MarkerClusterer utility
library, which I don't know if
you're taken a look at.
And that might actually give
you some ideas in terms of
algorithms that you could
employ for clustering.
AUDIENCE: Right.
Definitely.
Cool, thank you.
THOR MITCHELL: So I
think we have time
for one more question.
Maybe you want to grab it
while it's on the table.
AUDIENCE: Yesterday they talked
about the new canvas
overlay layer, but I didn't
see it in the doc set.
Is that coming soon, or did I
just miss it and didn't look
in the right place?
MANO MARKS: Brendon Kenny is
about to release that into the
utility library.
I don't know that it's actually
gone out yet but--
AUDIENCE: Oh, it's in
the utility library,
not the Maps API.
MANO MARKS: It's an open source
project, and I believe
he said it will be part of the
utility library, so yeah.
AUDIENCE: OK.
I was just looking in
the wrong place.
Thank you.
MANO MARKS: No problem.
MANO MARKS: I think we actually
have time for one
more quick question.
PETER BIRCH: I have
a question.
Thor, you talked about a lot of
great API stuff yesterday.
What's the new API that you're
most excited about?
Choose one of your children
THOR MITCHELL: Susannah's in
my ear going, Transit,
Transit, say Transit.
I'm surprised.
So I'm going to hedge my bets
and say there are two things.
So one service that you may not
have heard of unless you
attended one our sessions, I
think it was earlier today,
was we announced we are working
on a new API for asset
tracking, tailored to asset
tracking companies, which
essentially allows you to--
we already have a large number
of customers who use the Maps
API in conjunction with their
asset tracking business.
And right now, we don't have
any tools particularly
tailored to them.
And asset tracking has some
interesting challenges of its
own because what you tend to
find is that the amount of
data that's generated on a
day-to-day basis can be quite
significant.
And so we are building custom
infrastructure to support
collecting very, very, very
high volumes of vehicle
locations over time and then
make it easy for you to store,
serve, render, analyze.
There's also some very
interesting things we can do
because we have access to the
underlying map data to improve
the quality of that data
and provide interesting
added-value services on top.
So that's a very exciting
project, which I think you'll
see evolve over the course of
the next six to nine months.
The feature that we launched
at this event that most
excites me that's available
right now is the symbols work
that was just mentioned.
If you haven't seen that, we
posted to the blog on that
yesterday with some examples.
The interesting thing about
symbols-- and this is the
feedback that I've had
repeatedly all day, including
from a senior VP as Google--
is that you don't appreciate the
potential and the value of
this feature until you see it.
It seems like such
a simple idea.
But when you see what you can
do, it's extraordinary.
So I would encourage you to
take a look at the geo
developer blog, and have a look
at the demos on there,
and start thinking about ways
you can use that because we
think it will inspire an
amazing wave of new
interesting Maps API
applications and
visualizations.
There was a blog post yesterday
which said something
like, I think this feature will
revolutionize online mapping.
And we went, oh, that's
very nice.
Thank you.
OK, and with that, the red light
is telling me that we
are out of time.
So thank you all for
coming along.
[APPLAUSE]